mariupol is being bombed into the past
ukrainians say economic infrastructure
factories warehouses are non-military
targets
survivors now suffering war
will inevitably suffer in the future
their livelihoods destroyed
on the ground russia's chechen soldiers
hardened fighters continue to push on
residential areas and suburbs
waiting to meet them may be ukrainian
volunteers like these men
actors singers artists
all
defending their home
so far all people are volunteers
who basically never had a gun in their
hands never served in the army they
never thought that they would have a gun
in their hands
but all of them are with all of their
intentions determined to resist
and this desire just brought all of them
here
fear is natural he says to control it
you must embrace it
a small unit with little training
days away from going into the fray
to block russia's advance on the capital
mariopol kiev chernikev satellite
pictures show the russian army's use of
artillery where its ground forces have
been stalled by lethal ukrainian
hit-and-run attacks
in khaki region another enemy jet was
shot down
our forces have already shot down so
many russian jets and helicopters that
we can only state instead of containing
brains their pilot's heads are empty i
said as well and this is not by accident
their hearts and souls are also empty
the bombardment of mikolaiv seemingly
reaching new lows of brutality a strike
on a hospital for people suffering
mental illness
how can i put it i feel so much
resentment and i want to cry because we
had a connection between ukraine and
russia and russian cruelty is so brutal
there's nothing i can say they're bad
people it's not a human way to treat
people it's unkind
i'm just speechless
not even a month into the war the un
world health organization says half a
million of the refugees from ukraine who
fled into poland have problems with
their mental health
the pace and the scale of this crisis is
unprecedented as is the strain on the
people living it
with the number of refugees now about
half of them about half a million
require support for mental health
disorders due to the conflict and about
30 000
with
severe mental diseases
fierce fighting continues in residential
areas of mariopol
setting homes on fire
off the coast of the southern port city
ukrainian soldiers reportedly used a
guided anti-tank missile to sink a
russian boat
unharmed but not untouched by the
fighting
performers in drogobic have new roles
cooking meals for soldiers on the front
lines
there's a saying that when the gun sound
muses are silent but we are not silent
we are in the rear we are engaged in
volunteer work because ukraine is in a
difficult situation now
since the invasion began they've sent
thousands of meatballs and dumplings as
well as meat stew soup fish and pancakes
from here to kiev
as long as their people remain in harm's
way for this theater troupe the show
must go on zayn basravi al-jazeera la
viv